the doors are closed no more debates no
more votes Boris Johnson might be happy
with that but MPs certainly aren't
rowing with opponents than each other
why they think someone with an appalling
record like the leader of the Opposition
is fit not just is fit not just it's fit
well I'll check well get the honorable
lady behind me ask - I don't go and sit
somewhere else I'm sitting here I'm
standing here even the speaker lost his
rag as Parliament's that late into the
night racing through legislation and
debate don't tell me young man from a
sedentary position what I can and can't
say in your petty [ __ ] objection it
was a bad-tempered end to the longest
session of Parliament since the English
Civil War the Prime Minister is running
away from scrutiny if he is making if as
he claims he is making progress
mr. Johnson lost a sixth vote the eyes
to the right
293 the nose to the left
46 his second on a general election the
house to trust the people but once again
the opposition think they know better
and opposition MPs protested the
suspension of Parliament
[Applause]
chanting and booing as conservatives
left the chamber and the speaker
criticized the decision
[Music]
another vote lost and the second time
labor has blocked a general election
despite the party saying it wants to go
to the polls as the fault lines grow in
the Conservative Party Boris Johnson may
have taken the heat out of Parliament by
suspending it for a couple of weeks but
it won't solve his brexit problem and
time is running out
MPs are now without Commons levers to
help their cause while mr. Johnson too
is hamstrung unable to secure the
election he wants locked at loggerheads
Parliament and the government are in
limbo an All Eyez sent of Brussels a mr.
Johnson's negotiating team who have just
weeks to win a deal and hope it will be
enough to unite a deeply divided house
Kate McCann's Sky News